hi shelby
hey steve
come on
more or less
you don't hear that that much
of a like if you're not tremendously
great you would say way
something like that
like wow you know
you can say that come see is like this
come is like right
so come see kamsa
like this like that but you said that
people don't actually say that very much
it seems to me i don't hear that as
often but um maybe they do i don't know
we always have some
uh native figure come in and correct or
at least offer a native speaker's
perspective which is good
yes so uh i want to talk a bit before we
get into reviewing your um you know your
lessons with you and remember that there
are 60 mini stories
uh you don't have to just do many
stories you can do other things like
your songs or your uh you know the past
or anything that you know you're
interested in
but i would like you to uh you know make
sure you knock back your five mini
stories every week
and review the ones you did earlier
because again it's if i look at my
playlist i've listened to those earlier
ones 30 40 50 times
um
and then as so we're going to move uh
past the uh the first 20. in the second
20 we're going to speak a little mixed
french in english and then we're in
40 and beyond we're only going to speak
french so that's kind of the progression
uh i just wanted to kind of talk a bit
about the many stories and why i think
they have certainly they have changed my
whole approach to language learning they
have gotten me to speaking earlier
uh to me the many stories is first of
all a place to get some
you know repetitive exposure to the nuts
and bolts of the language the most
common verbs the most common
conjunctions you know however and
nevertheless and stuff like that
and
to get some some rhythm in the language
but it's not only that it's also a place
to review so i have an interview in
italian tomorrow and i haven't done any
italian so i'm going through the mini
stories and i've spoken lots of italian
i've listened to audiobooks in italian
i've read books in italian and yet when
i listen to the mini stories for the end
time i always pick things up so once
you've done a lot of the mini stories
you have a place
it's like your little language gym you
can always go back to it and work on
things so
but
obviously
each person is different now you were
saying that the french many stories
the voice is putting you off right yeah
yeah um
we in a previous video you and i
couldn't even distinguish if that was
the text to speech or if it was an
actual person speaking
we've determined it is an actual person
and uh yeah she she speaks really fast
which
i have a love hate thing with you know
because speaking fast
is
natural you know she's she's speaking i
think the way she just would
so it's good
practice for me but then sometimes when
i'm
like uh yesterday i was actually
practicing saying back what she was
saying and
it was hard for me to speak as fast as
she did therefore it didn't sound the
same way so yeah like her voice is uh
yeah it is a little bit tricky for me so
like i said love hate thing at the
moment about that okay so but i do like
the mini stories
they are i i like also that i get to
practice questions because they are
quite different right um than
spanish you know like that's kind of
what i'm comparing it to oh absolutely
absolutely
or whatever guess what
yeah but yeah those ones
that's great now a couple of couple of
bits of advice first of all i agree with
you on the voice and the voice has to be
pleasant
and uh
you know we have to like what we're
listening to and the quality of the
voice just the person's voice we like
some people's voices better than others
and if we don't like the voice that's a
big negative
the speed thing as well now i can
remember when i started learning chinese
the guy was speaking so fast
it was annoying i was angry i said are
you doing this torture me like what's
going on here
and but eventually i got used to it
but i must say like uh when i had the
greek many stories done this tremendous
guy in greece it was quite reasonable
uh he went through them so fast i said
please redo them slowly
because actually when you're getting
started
and even in terms of wanting to notice
the language or wanting to repeat
slower is better at first you'll have
plenty of time to interact with fast
french so i'm going to look into our
french mini stories and maybe we redo
them more slowly so okay
well i know i have the option there's a
slow down button so i can play the audio
more slowly
[Music]
doesn't sound as natural but i do love
um i don't know if we've talked about it
on this series but there's a youtuber
named hugo cotton yeah he does this
inner french and and he speaks really
slowly and so it's a nice balance so
i'll watch some of his videos too and
i'm like oh
that's what it sounds like to pronounce
everything exactly and when you repeat
are you in sentence mode and then
repeating them there or you just
yeah so that's yeah so that's again
something we talked about which is quite
useful to do and i was doing it in my
italians now
but she's the italian she speaks so
slowly that's by the way something you
have to look forward to shelby because
once you got your french done and with
your spanish you know
in your pocket
you can go after italian
might as well yeah
but uh so we may have to redo the french
mini stores because that's very
important people start with that
yeah i would be curious to know if
anyone who watches these videos um what
what you guys think about the the voice
of the french mini stories
okay
so
the the importance of the many stories
we covered and the importance is maybe
of making sure it's slow enough and that
the voice is pleasant
very very important points here we are
in my mini stories okay
um
[Music]
mini story nine
or two sure uh just uh before you get
going just to show people that uh you've
been through these
uh we've got zero um zero blue words so
you've converted all your blue words
and we have varying numbers i guess 14
was a bit tough for you've got 18 16 or
15 was easier the yellow words are the
words that you have saved and you don't
yet feel comfortable that you know them
which is fine which is a typical pattern
that's exactly where i would be
yeah
i i don't want to rush it
absolutely i like keeping them there
they show up i can review them i'm
reminded of them
i don't like to kill off my yellow words
i can always bring them back but it's
useful to have them there
yeah absolutely and
especially because you know they're
they're going to show up in the review
and of course i haven't really spent
much time review doing the actual review
at all so i started this week to try to
do um your method which is just to do
the
review when you turn the page right and
i'm really liking that because it's a
good way to sort of solidify a little
bit more what you just read and not not
waste too much time on the flash cards
because it it gets very repetitive and
boring just definitely exactly and again
my approach to flash cards is just that
they're another form of exposure just
introduces a variety in terms of the
form of exposure that we have right yeah
i don't i don't try and scratch my brain
if i get it wrong i get it wrong it's
just flipping through them yeah and i
noticed by the way that the you see the
little thumbs up so different people
have liked these stories 64 people 52
people
and unfortunately most people begin with
a lot of enthusiasm and then they uh
become lessons with the enthusiastic so
in most courses the first few lessons
have a lot of thumbs up and then we got
fewer few oh no number six got a 95
171 for yeah you see at the beginning
oh yeah yeah yeah so that's 289 now i
don't know if people lose interest or
they just stop giving it a thumbs up for
a while maybe so anyway
just i haven't been giving any of them a
thumbs up because
i'm so lost in my
grammar and vocab that i've been
distracted but i i like all of them i'll
go back and give them all the thumbs up
okay
sounds good okay jump into whichever
story you want um let's go into i think
we touched on nine last time so let's go
into ten
these
okay
all right and we're doing sentence mode
all right
time for me to pronounce it
sure if you want you want to translate
you offer the translation for people who
are following let's do that
all right
jack vaughn suareza
now what is always going to be a problem
not always but for a while is going to
be the
ira i know as soon as i said it i
thought of the uh
it comes with time like don't even worry
about it but and particularly when
you're going jacques vaughn
so it's not if it started like um okay
you'd have an easier time but when
you're actually in the middle you know
it's like a 100 yard hurdle race or
something all of a sudden you got to do
this thing so it's tough yeah and
especially with the
the girl who narrates this one she says
it so fast i'm like how can i
hear
you and
so natural for her
but we've got to we're going to do
something about that we got to try and
get someone do them a little slower
okay but other than that no particular
issues
is that a question yeah
um
that
i i guess
okay so is
is an evening
you know uh but a party as well right
yeah yeah i had to double check that one
yeah i wasn't sure let's see what what
they give us this meaning if you click
on sweaty
yep i got evening evening and party yeah
okay also um
[Music]
is this evening right this evening yeah
so so suarez what else
is more of a party but like an evening
like if you went to someone's place and
you had a very pleasant evening you said
ben is fluffy oh okay so evening kind of
like the event of the evening the event
of the evening
but you might say it's a bell
like possibly if it's a beautiful sunset
or it's just a slightly different
meaning
uh of the word
but yeah i love learning words that
don't have like
you know the perfect perfect translation
okay one other thing
go back a step there
like uh
anime
do you think that's masculine or
feminine
i think it is
masculine correct
the tendency is you see an e you'll get
used to seeing so many words you know
nouns in french that end in e that are
feminine
you might
be tended to think that you intend to
think that that anime is feminine that's
where you have an advantage because you
just think of spanish
right that's what you taught me last
week so i was like
what is it in spanish
right it's a good trick
thanks for that okay
all right
which we don't find in the other latin
well in italian they have bisogno but
they use it differently so elaborate is
very french
so say it again
like apostrophe
but then you also have the
the d there okay
typically uh speakers of spanish and
italian they tend to pronounce the e
they tend to say because they're used to
pronouncing that in their language right
but in french the uh often kind of
disappears
like the schwa which they teach in
english like you don't hear it
which they translate as meg for some
reason anyway
oh no it's reversed because it was
written in english and so the translator
changed meg which isn't a french name to
marguerite okay my mom's name is meg
well it's her nickname and it's short
for um margaret okay
so that's why they transition
okay
so here again no matter what i say the
reverse is also true
rarely would you say spawned on it's
there you actually hear the uh
[Music]
i guess it depends where the stress is
uh here they put the though in english
at the end but
suppondo at the beginning nevertheless
it's very common conjunction
all
right okay
question
could easily understand that as he asks
himself
right which is
kind of the same thing as wondering
right exactly i love that but that's
what it is
i wonder that's used all the time it's a
very useful it is very useful yeah and i
love it because spanish doesn't really
have like an eye wonder
statement it's more just using the uh
subjunctive tense
okay well i mean we could go on through
the whole lesson here
but uh you have to go through and
explore on your own
we just go in there to pick out a few
things sort of a random
you know sampling of things and continue
on okay
[Music]
you